THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT ON FOX.
BUT FIRST A MAJOR SHIFT IN
POLICY IS THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
BE PAYING ATTENTION TO.
YESTERDAY WALMART WHICH IS THE
WORLD'S LARGEST RETAILER
ANNOUNCED IT'S NOT TAKING SIDES
IN THE GUN DEBATE.
THE COMPANY ANNOUNCED IT WILL NO
LONGER SELL HANDGUN AMMUNITION
AND IT STORES NOR WILL IT STOP,
RIFLE ROUNDS THAT CAN BE "ALSO
USED IN LARGE CAPACITY CLIPS ON
MILITARY STYLE WEAPONS."
THEN THE COMPANY WENT FURTHER
THAN THAT.
DOUG McMILLON, THE CEO, ISSUED
A STATEMENT CALLING ON CONGRESS
TO BAN MANY SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLES
AND AMERICANS HAS AS WELL AS TO
SEIZE FIREARMS FROM SOME
AMERICANS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME OR EVEN
CHARGED WITH ANYTHING.
FOR A COMPANY THAT OPERATES
PRIMARILY IN RURAL AMERICA, ALL
OF THIS WAS A BIG STEP.
HOW DO RURAL AMERICANS FEEL
ABOUT IT?
WE CAN ONLY GUESS AT THAT,
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF POLLING
GOING ON IN MONTANA OR ROXBURY,
MAINE.
BUT IN THE MOST EXPENSIVE PARTS
OF NEW YORK AND LOS ANGELES ALL
THE SMART PEOPLE WERE DEEPLY
IMPRESSED AND THEY LOVE WALMART
NOW.
>> YOU KNOW, GOOD FOR WALMART
FOR DOING THIS.
THESE ARE WEAPONS OF WAR.
>> MAY BE WHAT'S HAPPENING AS
WALMART IS LISTENING TO ITS OWN
CUSTOMERS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, NOT ONLY IN STORES BUT
IN SOCIETY.
>> YOU HAVE BUSINESSES BEING
ABLE TO ENACT IN A MORE
ENLIGHTENED THAN GOVERNMENT WAY
THAN WALMART DOES.
>> WALMART ANNOUNCED THE
STATUS QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE.
>> I WAS HAPPILY SURPRISED, I
THINK IT'S A MOMENTOUS DECISION,
A WATERSHED MOMENT.
>> Tucker: SO NOW WALMART IS
NOW MORE "ENLIGHTENED THAN
GOVERNMENT IS" AS LIBERALS.
AND THAT'S A FASCINATING TURN
AROUND FOR YEARS TO REMEMBER
WALMART WAS THE TOPIC OF
COORDINATED ATTACKS FROM THE
LEFT.
PROGRESSIVES USE TO ATTACK THE
COMPANY FOR DESTROYING
SMALL-TOWN AMERICA AND
EXPLOITING WORKERS.
THE COMPANY NEVER REALLY CHANGE
THE WAY IT DOES BUSINESS AND
YET, SOMEHOW THE LEFT HAS MOSTLY
STOPPED ATTACKING THEM.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
PART OF THE ANSWER IS THAT
LIBERALS GOT RICH AND THEN LOST
INTEREST IN ECONOMICS.
THEY ADOPTED IDENTITY ISSUES
INSTEAD.
BUT WALMART FIGURED OUT I COULD
BUY IMMUNITY FROM CRITICISM FROM
THE LEFT BY MELTING LEFT WING
PIETIES, WHICH IS ALL IT TAKES.
SOUNDING WOKE AND THEY WILL
LEAVE YOU ALONE.
NOTICE THAT WALMART PLANS TO
SELL THE REMAINDER OF ITS AR-15
AMMUNITION SO THIS COULD REALLY
BE ABOUT SAVING LIVES OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S ABOUT THE MONEY, IT'S ONLY
ABOUT THE MONEY, AND THAT'S NOT
A SURPRISE BECAUSE THERE IS A
LOT OF MONEY AT STAKE.
I REVENUE WALMART IS THE LARGEST
IN THE WORLD.
THE WALTON FAMILY COLLECTIVELY
IS WORTH MORE THAN $150 BILLION.
HOW DID THEY GET SO RICH?
SELLING FOREIGN GOODS TO
DOMESTIC CONSUMERS.
CHEAP CHINESE GARBAGE, WHICH IS
THAT AMERICAN MANUFACTURERS
COULD NEVER MATCH.
ACCORDING FROM ONE STUDY,
AMERICA ACTUALLY LOST 400,000
JOBS THANKS TO WALMART'S
RELIANCE ON CHINESE IMPORTS, AND
IT SHOWS.
IS WHAT MANY AMERICAN TOWNS LOOK
LIKE TODAY THANKS TO WALMART.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE GLEAMING
NEW CITY IS THAT THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE GOVERNMENT BUT WITH THE
PROPHETS.
LOOK AT THAT.
DON'T YOU WISH WE HAD THAT?
WE DON'T.
AT TIMES, WALMARTS SOLD THE
GOODS AT A LOSS JUST LONG ENOUGH
TO DRIVE AMERICAN COMPETITORS
OUT OF BUSINESS COMPLETELY.
SMALLER RETAILERS AND THE JOBS
THEY PROVIDED JUST VANISHED.
IN MANY PLACES WALMART BECAME
ONE OF THE FEW REMAINING
EMPLOYERS.
AS OF TODAY WITH MORE THAN ONE
AT A HALF-MILLION AMERICANS AT
ONE TIME WORK AT WALMART AND
IT'S NOT BY AND LARGE AN
IMPROVEMENT OVER WHAT WE HAD
BEFORE AND IT'S NOT GETTING
BETTER.
IN 2005, THE MAJORITY WORK
PART-TIME.
WHY?
IF WALMART KEEPS EMPLOYEES ARE
AS ENOUGH THEY CAN AVOID PAYING
THEM BENEFITS.
PEOPLE CAN'T LIVE LIKE THAT AND
WALMART KNOWS IT BUT THEY KNOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR YOU
TAXPAYERS WILL SUBSIDIZE LOW
WAGES WITH HEALTH CARE BENEFITS.
IN OTHER WORDS YOU ARE WORKING
SO THE WALTON FAMILY WON'T HAVE
TO PLAY THEIR EMPLOYEES ENOUGH
TO LIVE.
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW BUT
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WALMART IS NOW PUSHING
GUN CONTROL.
BUT GO BACK AND LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THE COMPANY IS MORE RESPONSIBLE
FOR
THR
THAN ANY COMPANY FOR DESTROYING
AND DEGRADING NORTH AMERICA.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO PUSHED THE
APPALLING WALK LIE THAT BRIGHTLY
COLORED PLASTIC FROM CHINA WILL
MAKE US HAPPY, THAT COMPANY IS
NOW LECTURING NORMAL AMERICANS,
THE AMERICANS THEY HAVE HEARD,
ABOUT HOW IMMORAL THEY ARE FOR
DARING TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
WITH FIREARMS.